let's take you back to covid some
breaking news for you the government has
announced that pre-departure covert
tests will be a requirement for all
people traveling to the uk now that is
an effort to clamp down on the number of
cases of the omicron variant being
brought into the country nigeria has
also been added to the uk's red list
that makes it the 11th african country
on that red list the health secretary
sajid javid has been setting out the
details of those plants in the past few
minutes
yeah since we learned of this new
variant our strategy has been to buy
time buy time to assess it but also to
put in place protective measures and
we've always said that we would act
swiftly should new data require it over
the recent days we have learned of a
significant number of growing cases
linked to travel with nigeria there are
27 cases already in england and that's
growing and nigeria now is second only
to south africa in terms of linked cases
to omicron so today the government has
decided to add nigeria to the travel red
list and that will be effective from 4
am on monday which will mean that only
uk
citizens or residents of the uk can
enter the uk from nigeria from that
point onwards and they will have to
quarantine in one of the relevant hotels
we have also decided to require
pre-departure tests that's for all
inward travelers that will be effective
from 4 a.m on tuesday and they will be
required a maximum of 48 hours before
the departure time though we've been
clear that we will take action if it is
necessary but it is important that
whilst we are introducing these new
border measures today that to remember
that vaccinations remember they are our
first line of defense and uh the booster
program the expansion in the brewster
program is hugely important and can i
please just remind everyone if they do
get their call from the nhs when it's
their turn please do step up roll up
your sleeve and get protected
and what's triggered the pre-departure
tests being announced kind of why has
that change come in
we've kept the data under review over
the last week or so since we learned
about omicron and we're seeing
increasing number of cases linked to
travel and again we've always said we
will act swiftly if we need to if the
changing data requires that and that's
why we've decided to bring in this
change on pre-departure tests now i will
stress these are temporary measures we
want to remove them as soon as we
possibly can but before
we learn more about omicron it is right
that we have these measures in place
and with the pre-departure tests and so
neighbours call for them sage spoke
about that being a sensible idea at the
start of the week why the wage
i think it's really important at a time
like this to have a balanced and
proportionate approach the measures that
we introduce around this time last week
uh which were around the the pcr test
the day two pcr tests when everyone
arrives back in the uk and
self-isolating until you get a negative
result and some of the other measures
around red listing countries i think
they've been the right response but when
the situation changes if it requires
more action it's absolutely right the
government acts swiftly so with these
new measures what does this tell us
about the spread of the omicron variant
we've got about 130 cases that are
absolute confirmed cases across the uk
uh
that's actually in england and across
the uk i think around 160 cases and so
it is it is growing and we do expect
many more uh cases uh but at this point
in time with the interventions that
we're taking so for example the
self-isolation changes for those that
come into close contact with someone
that has a suspected case of omicron
these are all helping but we will keep
all of this under review and again if we
do need to take further action we will
and how many people will be affected by
these new measures
well it depends on how the measures may
actually in fact impact the desire uh to
travel uh of course it is uh something
that's going to particularly uh hit
people that were had travel plans and
that is hugely unfortunate but i think
the vast majority of people understand
exactly why it is important to take
action so we can have a much less
incursion of this variant into the uk
and what about british travelers already
in nigeria
for for travelers that are already in
nigeria they will know of this
at this point and they will have to put
in to you put in place uh measures uh
for the managed quarantine system and
there will be advice available for them
on the uk government website
so do we have any update on just how
serious the omicron variant might be
there's been reports that it might cause
mild infections but are there any
updates in that point
i'm afraid there's no further update to
this point we are still working actively
both our scientists here in the uk
working with their international
partners just yesterday i had a call
with the head of the world health
organization and we're working closely
with all our international partners to
learn what we
should people can prepared to change or
cancel potentially christmas plans
i think people should carry on uh with
their plans and they should uh make
plans to enjoy christmas as usual uh the
guidelines that have always been there
are still there the ones we set out a
few months ago even before this variant
of course we've known all along that
covidien and flu for that matter it
likes the darker colder days that winter
brings so you know just uh follow the
guidelines that are there about you know
hand hygiene and having ventilation
where you can but most of all enjoy
yourselves
so we're seeing more kind of
international restrictions come in um if
the situation gets worse won't we have
to bring in more domestic restrictions
we will keep the situation under a view
as we've always said but i think that
today's action again shows that whenever
the government needs to act we will